1957 alfred hitchcock sat down with
writer samuel taylor to discuss the
script for the movie vertigo within the
very first moments taylor knew that
there was no way he could stray from
hitchcock's vision for the film
hitchcock was an outstanding storyteller
his description of the concept of the
movie was so vivid that he could
mesmerize his listeners he was so
certain about his narrative and so
confident about his story that
the only task left to the scriptwriter
was to fill the blanks left by
hitchcock's narration when the script
was ready and the shooting commenced the
stage was transformed into the most
elaborate acting place
lights camera positions blocking and
dimensions were carefully arranged in
order to allow a smooth and rigorous
shooting hitchcock's directing style was
meticulous yet calm while most
filmmakers are energetic and oftentimes
aggressive yelling at their crew and
barking out orders hitchcock's attitude
was characterized by serenity and
patience he would sit in his chair and
he would sedately monitor and supervise
the set oftentimes even apathetically
his actors could get annoyed and even
frustrated but eventually they would
come to realize that his attitude is
infectious in the course of time
everybody will respect his rules and his
films would be produced in a way that
was transgressing the principles of
ordinary filmmaking the secret to
hitchcock's attitude wasn't his special
character or his high intelligence it
was his obsession with planning and
influence hitchcock wasn't an ordinary
director he was a director a strategist
and an expert in human nature a great
example of his influential character was
highlighted in an argument he had with
actress kim novak when the actress
refused to wear a gray suit in vertigo
because she felt it made her look washed
out hitchcock told her he wanted her to
look like a woman of mystery who had
just stepped out of the san francisco
fog how could she argue with that to me
alfred hitchcock represents the
quintessence of the socially and
emotionally intelligent person he's a
man who managed to transcend the regular
and become a strategic warrior in the
battlefield of life because whether we
like it or not sometimes it feels like a
battlefield out there despite our most
gentle intentions the mere structure of
society and the complexity of our
emotional and social world
make our life conditions difficult to
manage in the midst of this battle
people can only maintain emotional
stability by staying detached and
managing their interactions with
patience and empathy as robert greene
very elegantly states in the 33
strategies of war our successes and
failures in life can be traced to how
well or how badly we deal with
inevitable conflicts that confront us in
society the common ways that people deal
with them trying to avoid all conflict
getting emotional and lashing out
turning sly and manipulative are all
counterproductive in the long run
because they are not under conscious and
rational control and often make the
situation worse strategic warriors
operate much differently they think
ahead toward their long-term goals and
decide which fights to avoid and which
are inevitable know how to control and
channel their emotions
this mindset is the only way to help one
bring equilibrium to their emotional
world and most probably the catalyst
that can lead to a proper way to deal
with human nature since i usually favor
structure over abstraction in this video
i will suggest four pillars that
according to my world view
are the cornerstones of this mindset
[Music]
each individual is an amalgamation of
biological cultural and social
influences this complicated mixture
suggests that it is almost impossible to
find individuals whose opinions can
align perfectly the idea that we tend to
idealize our expectations and hope that
the narrative of others won't interfere
with our personal narrative is naive and
irresponsible to say the least this is a
clear symptom of a character that
voluntarily denies growing up and
accepting the responsibilities of
adulthood you see it all over the
internet nowadays where certain online
ecosystems feel more like nurseries than
places where adults can exchange
insightful views and ideas in my opinion
high expectations should only be
established on a purely personal level
expecting a lot from yourself and
managing to craft a plan that can help
you reach your expectations is a sign of
a mature and emotionally healthy
individual constantly expecting a lot
from others and showcasing your
dissatisfaction when the expectations
are not met constitutes an ill obsession
alfred hitchcock rarely discussed
expectations with the members of the set
his choices were strategically planned
and once he decided on the players of
the game he only adapted his moves in
order to regulate the behaviors and the
reactions of its player he could
properly identify the strengths and the
weaknesses of its actor and according to
what was at play in a given moment he
knew how to strategize his approach
since the establishment of our species
as the dominant force on our planet we
experience an omnipresent struggle how
to reconcile individualism with
collectiveness this struggle has led to
innumerable fights wars and atrocities
however it has also led to innumerable
lessons that if properly construed can
lead to the re-engineering of the way we
co-exist and this is the state of
affairs we experience in the present day
personally the closest i have come to
achieving the perfect balance between
individuality and togetherness is when i
realized that the idea of self is an
illusion sam harris explains why in one
of his interviews now that sense of
being a subject a locus of consciousness
inside the head
is an illusion that it makes no
neuroanatomical sense there's no place
in the brain for your ego to be hiding
we know that that everything you
experience your your conscious emotions
and thoughts and
and moods and the the impulses that
initiate behavior all of these things
are
delivered by by
myriad different processes in the brain
that are spread out over the whole of
the brain that they can be independently
erupted there's
we have a changing system we are a
process and there's not one unitary self
that's carried through from one moment
to the next unchanging and yet we feel
that we have this this self is just this
kind of center of experience this
profound statement can have a galvanic
effect on the way one perceives the idea
of ego self and togetherness
in an article published back in february
2016
the new york times approached a very
interesting topic
google's quest to build the perfect team
based on a research conducted within
google that aimed to identify the key to
successful team building the major
finding was that a combination of
conversational turn-taking and average
social sensitivity is what helps a team
stay strong conversational turn-taking
refers to the ability of the team to
allow each of the members to express
their opinion about the topic average
social sensitivity refers to how easy it
is for members of a team to intuit how
others felt based on their tone of voice
their expressions and other non-verbal
cues this showcases two things one that
people want to feel safe and two that
people want to be understood in simple
words psychological safety and empathy
human nature is very fragile imagine a
creature that wants to feel understood
and safe but requires training in order
to exhibit such behaviors towards others
that creature is a very tortured
creature we are hostages of our own lack
of ability to do to others what we want
others to do to us and that's something
very crucial to have in mind
candor means frankness and
forthrightness candor highlights the
ability of the individual to demonstrate
not just truth-telling but a lack of
reserve it is closely related to
assertiveness and it can be considered
the quintessential tool for
self-exploration the subtlety with
regards to candor is that it entails a
level of dynamism that is extremely
liberating kander is also very
sophisticated it is not honesty for the
sake of being honest it is honesty with
a purpose kander offers the chance to
the individual to be honest for the
right reasons in a world that constantly
oscillates between victimization and
injustice
speaking our minds and speaking the
truth a truth that is based on morality
and reason is the most legitimate
expression of our desire to transcend
the limitations imposed by our nature
you